Yeah.
They sound
interest like like
He's like a huge
down the corridor.
No, it's a somebody the person next to
me has a large office and he wanted to
stay in a large office. We have three
largest office, one of the large three
and he said, you know, they asked me
whether I'd be willing to give up my
larger office for a smaller office.
Okay, folks.
Okay, just a very couple of quick
reminders in case you need them. The
first is we have 10 days left in the
class.
Right. So everything's going to come at
you in a rush. So the nagging will
continue and will not stop till May 5th.
So I'll keep reminding you of things to
do. You've done your DCF and you're on
your way to pricing. You're pretty close
to done. So at this point, it's just
pulling together. I'll send you some
details about the final exam tomorrow
and and kind of the logistics of that.
No, but expect emails from now through
May 5th pretty much every day, perhaps
twice a day. So, so today we're going to
continue our discussion of real options
and rather than put you on the start of
the class test, which is what I usually
do, I'm going to frame the start of the
class
question. Let's say I have the rights to
a nonviable technology. You know what do
you mean by nonviable, right? Today if I
try to develop it the cost of de
developing it exceeds what I will get as
cash
flows and let's say let's make give this
nonviable technology a frame of
reference. It's an AI technology. Let's
speed up the processing of data make it
less expensive but right now it's not
viable. I own the rights to this
technology. If you're Apple or Microsoft
or Google might you be willing to pay a
price for that nonviable technology? Uh
what
viable cash flows matter. In other
words, when I compute the viability, I
look at the cash flows from developing
it today. The cost of developing it
today. And all I'm saying is today the
cash flows are less than the cost. I
wouldn't develop it. But two years from
now when I look at it, who knows, right?
The cash flows could be different. The
cost could be different.
So you're buying it not because you're
being unrealistic and you expect to
develop the technology today, but
because you think this technology could
become viable. But address on me having
exclusive rights. If I didn't have
exclusive rights, you'd be crazy to buy
it, right? But if I have exclusive
rights, let's build on this theme that
value willing to attach to this
nonviable technology. Will it get
greater or smaller if I have more life,
more years of exclusive
rights? Go ahead, William. It should
increase, right? If I give you 15 years
of exclusive life, it should be worth
more than 10 years. And now comes the
magic. What will happen to the value of
this technology as you feel more
uncertain about the business that this
technology is in?
Ahan, it goes up. And that's where
everything we've talked about so far
seems to be turned on its head, right? I
mean, think of what I just told you. The
more uncertain you feel about the
future, the more you're willing to pay
for non-viable technology. Why is that?
Because the price you pay is your
maximum downside. And the more
uncertainty there is, the greater the
potential for
upside. That's at the heart of the real
options argument. So before we look at
real options, let's do some mopping up
because we still have to get the option
pricing part. Last session I talked
about what it is that makes an option an
option. It's a payoff diagram. That
unique payoff diagram where you have
limited losses potentially unlimited
profits. Second stop question I'm going
to ask is when does an option have
significant economic value? I'm going to
put out a word here that I want you to
remember in the context any real options
discussion that to me separates valuable
options from those that are not
valuable. The word is exclusivity.
If you and only you can have the rights
of the Rob, that option is worth a lot
more than if a lot of people have that
same
right. So let's take uh example Jake. Um
what's the name? Jake, right? You
wouldn't look up. So I wasn't sure
whether I got your name right. Oh, okay.
No, no, no. So you're taking it down. So
Jake, do you rent your apartment right
now? Not at home. You live at home?
That's tough to reframe. Anybody renting
their apartment?
you rent your apartment. Let's suppose
I'm your landlord. I'm not, but I'm not.
So, I'm your landlord and I give you the
right to buy the apartment you're
renting any time over the next year. How
much would you pay for that right?
Forgot to ask me something very
critical. William, what did he what is
the right What did I give him? The right
to buy his apartment. Right. What did I
not
mention?
Claire, I didn't mention a
price. Without a price, the right to buy
something is worthless, right? Because
the right to buy the prevailing market
price is worth
nothing. There's no
exclusivity. But if I said, I'll give
you the right to buy your apartment at
half a
million. There is an option. As long as
I don't go around offering homeless
people on the street the same right,
right?
It comes from that exclusivity that
comes from the
price. So when you're looking at
options, you're saying is there
exclusivity? And to the degree that
there's exclusivity, there will be a lot
of value. And to the degree that the
exclusivity gets weaker, it's not 01,
the value of the option is going to slip
away. So when you look at a real option
in addition to payoff diagram, you're
asking the question about exclusivity.
Let's now look at if there's
exclusivity, what is it that drives the
value of an option? There are only six
variables that determine the value of an
option. There's no debate to have about
it. Here are the six variables. Three
relate to the underlying asset. The
first is the value of the underlying
asset. As that goes up and down, the
value of all options on that asset will
go up and down. Right? With a call
option, you get the right to buy at a
fixed price. The underlying asset
becomes more valuable. The call option
is going to become more
valuable. The second is the variance in
that value. And here's where the magic
of options kicks in. The greater the
variance in that value, the underlying
asset, the more valuable all options,
calls as well as puts become on that
underlying asset. That limited loss
feature. And the third and this is
sometimes forgotten is any dividends you
expect to get on the underlying asset
will affect the value of your option.
Think of why. Let's say you have a
traditional call option on a
stock and tomorrow is supposed to be an
X dividend day. You know what next
dividend day is? That's the date in
which ownership of the dividend passes
from one person other. So you buy before
the X dividend day, you get the
dividend. You get it after you don't.
So, tomorrow is an X dividend day and
it's going to be a big dividend, $5
dividend per
share. What's going to happen tomorrow
to the stock price, Tyler? It'll drop
roughly $5. Maybe not quite because of
tax differences.
$4.93. Why does it affect you? What do
you have as a call option? The right to
buy it affects price, right? Every time
a company pays a dividend, the call
option becomes less valuable because the
price goes down and put options become
more valuable. Those are the three
variables relating to the underlying
asset. There are two relating to the
option itself. One is the strike price
of the option. The right to buy at a
lower price is worth more than the right
to buy at a higher price. So call
options become more valuable as the
strike price decreases and put options
become less valuable. And the longer I
give you in terms of time, the more
valuable all options become. There's
only one macro variable that affects
option pricing, which is what the
riskless rate is. You're saying, why
would I care? What do you get with a
call option? The right to buy at a fixed
price at the expiration date, which
might be year, two years, three years
from now. Right? As interest rates rise,
the present value of what you have to
pay becomes lower. Call options become
more valuable. The right to buy
something at $50 three years from now,
that $50 becomes a much lower number if
interest rates are 15%.
So, as interest rates go up, call
options become more valuable, put
options become less
valuable. Every option pricing model,
you're going to see those six
ingredients come into
play. So, we can see what makes for an
option, the payoff diagram. We see what
drives the value of an option is
exclusivity. Let's talk a little bit
about option pricing models. You've seen
these in your foundations class, at
least kind of. Don't don't worry, I'm
not going to probe you on specifics.
Kind of. No.
You might have seen the black shores
model. You don't remember it, I know,
but you have seen it, right? I'm going
to step back and talk a little bit about
the two building blocks that all option
pricing models are built on. The first
is this notion of
replication. What does that mean? That
you can create something that looks
exactly like the option in terms of cash
flows by combining the underlying asset
and either borrowing or lending. So,
we'll talk about what that combination
is, but you're going to create a
replicating portfolio. And if that
replicating portfolio has the same cash
flows as the option, you draw in a
second principle. It's called
arbitrage. What is the arbitrage
principle? If two things have the same
cash flows, they should be priced
exactly the same. I know it's abstract,
but the simplest way to see replication
at play is to actually look at this
replicating portfolio that delivers the
same cash flows. So, you have call
option. There's a combination of
borrowing money and buying a certain
number of units of shares in the company
that will give you the same cash flow as
a call option. With a put option,
selling short the stock and lending that
money out will give you the same cash
flows as a put option. Entire focus in
option pricing is to come up with that
replicating
portfolio. I'm going to show you the
black Scholes model in a couple of
minutes, but the best way to see
replication is with what's called a
binomial model. Binomial model is a very
simple model. The stock price at any
point in time can go to only one of two
two points. So if the stock price is 50
in a binomial model at t equal to 1 the
stock can either go to 70 or 35. If it
goes to 70 70 at t equal to 1 in the
following time period it can either go
to 100 or 50. If it goes to 35 it can
jump back to 50 or drop to 25. At t
equal to two the second time period the
stock can end up at 100if at 50 or at
25. Let's say you have a call option on
this stock with a strike price of
40. Two time period expiration. So it's
going to expire at t equal to two. Jake
help me out here. If you have call
option with a strike price of 40, how
much will you collect as cash flows? If
the stock goes to 100, what what will
you do? $60. You'll get $60. You you
exercise at 40. You sell it at 100, you
keep 60. If it goes to 50, you 10. If it
goes to
25, why not at minus 15?
Because it's your choice, right? The
stock goes to 25. Why would I be crazy
to go out and buy shares at 40 when I
can buy it at 25? So, it's zero. The
cash flows in the option. My job in
replication is to create a portfolio
that is exactly the same cash flows as
the call option.
And what are my two things that I play
with? The underlying asset, the shares
of stock and borrowing or lending. So
let's set up an algebra problem. Let's
say you have delta shares of stock and
be in borrowing. You think this is not
an algebra class? Hang in there. It's
not going to be that
complicated. Stock goes to 70. What do I
need to do? I need to borrow B dollars
and buy delta shares of stock. And that
position has to generate cash flows of
60 if the stock goes to 100 and 10 if it
goes to 50. agree because that's the
cash flow in the call. I don't know
which grade in school you did
simultaneous equations somewhere.
Seventh grade, eighth grade. If you have
two equations and two
unknowns, sooner or later, neither
should be unknown, right? You play with
it and you kind of that's basically what
I'm doing. I'm solving two simultaneous
equations and I end up with D equal to
364 and D equal 1. You're saying what
does it even mean? If the stock goes to
70 and I go out and borrow
$364 and buy one share of stock, I will
have a position that has exactly the
same cash flows as the
call. How much will it cost me my money
to create that position? I'm borrowing
364. That's not my money. I'm paying 70.
That difference of 3396 is what I would
have to spend to create the replicating
portfolio. arbitrage now kicks in. If
has the same cash flows as the call
option, the call has to trade for 33.96
if the stock goes to 70. So I know the
value of the call. Stock goes to 70. I
repeat the process if the stock goes to
to 35. There the cash flows have to be
10 if the stock goes to 50, zero if it
goes to zero. I solve for delta 10B.
Borrowing $91 and buying point4 shares
of stock. Don't even ask me how you buy
point4 shares. Let's say you can will
deliver exactly the same cash flows as
the call. That would cost me $4.99. That
becomes the value of the call. If the
stock goes to
35, you always have to start with the
last branch and work backwards because
that's the only branch where you know
the cash flows in the option. Now I
value the option. Stock price is 70 and
a stock price at 35. I go back to today.
I'm at 50. Again, I repeat the process.
How many shares of stock do I need to
buy? How much do I need to borrow? You
solve for that equation. Borrowing
$21.61 today and
buying.8278 shares of stock will give me
a position that has exactly the same
value as a call all the way through this
life. That position would have cost me
$1942. That becomes the value of the
call
option. the binomial tree you can see
the replication arbitrage work itself
back. The only problem with the binomial
tree is you can jump to only one of two
points the next time period. Which means
your time periods have to be really
really short, right? Because if I make
it a day, think of all the possible
prices that a Facebook or a Google can
go to. But if I make time 1 minute,
maybe I have a shot. Let's say I do
that. Every time period is one minute
and I have a threemonth option. You
ready? I want you to draw a binomial
tree of one minute time periods for
three months.
Can you visualize it? It's going to be
first you have to have a magnifying
glass and a really sharp pencil and you
draw a little branch and a tiny little
branch. Let's say you do this and you're
done. It's going to be this really dense
tree, right? Hang in there with me. I'm
going to flip the tree over on its
base. What does it look like? It looks
like a Christmas tree without a trunk.
Right? Then I smooth out the outsides of
the tree.
Think of a Christmas tree
with smoothed out sides. What does it
start to look like?
A normal
distribution. If as time gets shorter,
my price changes also become smaller.
The
binomial model becomes the black shores
model. The binomial tree becomes a
normal
distribution. The black shores model is
a special case of the binomial model. If
price changes get small as time periods
become
small now in the in the B in the black
Scholes world the way a stock goes from
35 to 50 it goes 35 3501 3502 that's a
continuous it never jumps it's kind of a
strange assumption in the real world but
it gets you this advantage of a normal
distribution and all of the pluses that
a normal distribution
gets. Could prices jump in short periods
especially after a month like this one?
And the answer is of course
right in the real world prices can jump.
There are versions of the option pricing
model that have been developed for jump
processes. One is called the posson
process. I know what they remember from
where you can have a price jump. They've
never acquired traction because getting
the inputs of those models is incredibly
messy. So I'm going to give you a very
quick intro to the Black Scholes model
in case you don't remember.
The Black Scholes model, the value of a
call option is a function of five
variables. S, which is the current value
of the underlying asset. K, which is the
strike price. T, which is the life of
the option, R, which is the riskless
rate. For some reason, Microsoft Word on
a PC converts my sigas from a Mac into a
box. But that's sigma squared. That's a
variance. Five. But did we mention six
variables that drive the value of an
option? What's the missing one?
SK which is you know
player I missed the dividends I'll give
you the story as to why dividends are
not part of the original black shows
Fisher Black and Marin shows taught at
the University of
Chicago
1971 they were working on this process
and in fact their breakthrough was
recogn because until 1971 people valued
option they treated it as if it were a
standalone asset. They took the expected
cash flows, tried to come up with the
risk adjusted discount rate and Fisher
Black and Marin Scholes said that
doesn't make any sense. It's a
derivative asset. We should be able to
value it by creating this replicating
portfolio which looks exactly like it
and tell and then figuring out how much
it will cost. So they started writing
the paper and they got 2/3 through the
paper and they got stuck. They got stuck
on this equation where to take a
derivative but it's normally we think
about calculus but traditional calculus
wouldn't work. It requires something
called stochastic calculus that nobody
in finance had ever used. Legend has it
they were stuck for weeks maybe even
months until a physics PhD student was
walking by came into their office
uninvited looked at the equations and we
see this all the time in
physics we use this etos lema and they
said what's etos lema and he took them
through this very basic process that
broke open the process and they came up
with the black schles model fisher black
and marin schles won a Nobel prize I
don't think the nameless this PhD
student in physics got any Nobel prizes
for doing it but he unlocked the
equation but they were stuck and they
were stuck to the point where they said
we're going to remove dividends this is
the classic economist problem to dealing
with the problem let's assume it away
the original black schles was designed
to value either non-ividend paying
stocks options or non-pay div or
dividend protected options you're saying
what's a dividend protected option
remember what drives the value of the
options when you have a dividend the
stock price drops drops by $5 or $3 or a
dollar. If you have a dividend protected
option, the exercise price is also
lowered when the stock price drops.
There isn't a single dividend protected
option that's actually trade in the
world. But in their model, they said,
"Let's ignore dividends." And if you
carry that model through, you've got the
Black Scholes
model. The way I describe the Black
Scholes model is it'll make you touch
all those keys in your calculator that I
call virgin keys.
keys you've never touched before. That
exponential key. The heck is that? That
ln big log g you say I've never touched
those keys. Right? This is just
basically when you look at the black
shores model, you see E minus RT. You
can say natural log. But let's take a
step back because embedded in this model
is that replicating portfolio we got in
the binomial model. First there's S. S
is the value of the stock or the
underlying asset today. It's not some
expected value. Then there's n d1.
You're saying what the heck is that?
Well, to get to d n of d1, first I need
a d1. And there's this elaborate
equation by itself. There's no intuitive
grasp to it. It's all the inputs that
drive an option pricing model go into
d1. Once you get d1, you go into a
normal distribution. And n of d1 is the
area under the distribution to the left
of d1.
You see what does that even tell me? N
of D1 N of D can go from zero to one.
It's like a probability. So N of D1 and
N of D2 are roughly speaking
probabilities. In fact, N of D2 in
particular has a very explicit meaning.
It's a riskneutral probability that your
option will end up in the money. You
know what in the money is, right? S is
greater than K. So n of D2 is 08.
There's an 80% chance your option will
be
exercised. Let me go back to the
previous page. This N of D1 is also
called the option delta. Remember how in
the black SHs I solve for the number of
shares of stock you need to buy. That's
in the black shores. The NFD1 is the
number of shares of the underlying stock
that you will have to buy to replicate
the
option. K minus RT is just a present
value of the strike strike price. Why
present value? Because black shows
models were designed to value European
options. European options can be
exercised only at expiration. And
because it can be exercised only at
expiration, you don't pay the strike
price till 3 months from now, 6 months
from now, two years from now. It's just
a present value factor. K minus RT times
N of D2 becomes the
borrowing embedded in the black shores
model. It's the same replicating
portfolio you saw in the binomial. you
just saved yourself a lot of time by not
having to do the branches and assuming a
normal
distribution. So that's the original
black shs. As you can see, it was
designed to value dividend protected
options.
Unfortunately, with real options, which
is going to be our topic, we will have
something like dividends in almost every
option. So, I'm going to give you a
version of the black shores that you're
going to see me use more today and on
Monday to value options.
In this model, I'm actually going to
allow my underlying stock to pay a
dividend. Let's think through how this
will play out. Remember the replicating
portfolio went out and borrowed money
and bought the underlying stock. When
you borrowed the money, you had to pay a
riskless rate. You have to borrow the
money. So, it's an interest rate. But if
your stock pays a dividend, what can you
do with the dividend? You can use the
dividend to pay some of the interest,
right? If you take the difference
between R and Y, the risk-free rate and
the dividend yield, you're getting a
carrying cost. So if risk-free rate is
5% and your dividend yield is 3%, you
need to come up with only 2% to cover
the cash flow. So that's the first
change. The second is every time a
dividend gets paid, what happens to the
stock price? It drops a little. So what
you would see is to the stock price I
add an extra factor, which is every
dividend yield is effectively a drop in
the stock price. So a 3% dividend yield,
I'm knocking your stock price down by 3%
ahead of the fact, saying there will be
a dividend. It reduces my S. This is the
dividend adjusted version of the black
shores. And this is the model you're
going to see as we go through this class
in terms of applying on real
options. Incidentally, that dividend
yield in real options is going to take
on an intuitive role. And effectively,
here's why we need it. Traditional
options, you buy an option. Let's say
you buy it in the right kind of stock.
The stock goes
up. It's a listed option. You will never
exercise the option.
Why? Traditional go to CBOE, you buy an
option, buy the right kind of option.
Why would you never exercise the option
before it's exercise date? Because you
can sell it. When you sell it, you get
the option, the exercise value plus a
time premium. So because of time
premiums and options 95% of options on
the CBOE get exercised at the last
moment of the very last day of their
lives. You're saying what about the
other 5%. The other 5% get
exercised just before an X dividend day.
And here's why. What do we say happens
on the X dividend day? The stock price
drops. Right? So we have a call option
and tomorrow is going to be a really big
X dividend day. Sometimes what you will
lose by waiting the day exceeds what you
will lose in terms of time premiums you
exercise early
on. We're going to use real options to
value patents to value natural resource
reserves. Let's say I have a patent for
the next 17 years and I value it as an
option and I don't have a dividend yet
or or the equivalent. What am I going to
do? I'm going to wait 16 years and 364
days and on the very last day I'm going
to start to develop the bet which makes
no sense at all right I've lost all the
protection I could get what the dividend
yield or the equivalent does in real
options it introduces the cost of
waiting I'm going to trigger you to
exercise early with real options
exercising early should be more the rule
than the exception because that's how
you make money so in my model whenever
you see dividend yields from this point
on think of it as a cost of waiting
And sometimes that cost of waiting will
be large enough that you choose not to
wait and exercise or you develop your
reserves. You convert your patent into a
product and that's effectively how you
end up making
money. Couple of uh final points. The
black shores model as I said was
designed for European options. Most real
options get exercised early.
Sophia because in options you own stock
and pay high dividend but remember you
have the call option on the you don't
own the stock you have a call option on
the stock right because you have a call
option until you exercise you can't
collect the dividend exactly that's why
it's a cost of waiting so if you wait
and you hold on to the option you never
get the shares you don't get the shares
you don't get to collect the dividend
that's why it's effectively the cost of
waiting
Okay, the black sh model was designed to
value European options. European options
can be exercised only at expiration. And
as I said, real options tend to get
exercised early. There are a lot of real
options purists who will argue you
should never use the black shores model
to value real options. Should use a
binomial model. Technically, they're
right. But I've tried drawing binomial
models for real options. It's an
incredible pain in the neck. all these
little branches, hundreds of branches.
You know what? I'm going to continue to
use the Black Scholes model to value
real options even though they get
exercised on you. Here's my defense.
When you use the Black Scholes model to
value an American option, remember
American options can be exercised any
time before exercise, you'll get a lower
bound on the value because effectively
you're removing the exercise rights. So,
I might underestimate your value in a
real option. I'm okay with that. So even
though the black shores was designed to
value European options, I'm going to
value American options using it and say
that's a lower bound. If you want to add
a premium on top of that because you can
exercise early, go ahead. But I'm not
going to give up on the model because a
binomial is just too intractable, too
difficult to work
with. Last point and then we will kind
of dig into real options. Guys familiar
with decision
trees? What do you do in a decision
tree? First, what kinds of risks are
decision trees best suited to deal
with? Discrete and sequential, right?
So, we used it for failure risk, but if
you have discrete and sequential risk, a
decision tree is a great way to capture
the risk. Think that's abstract. What
kind of businesses have discrete
sequential
risks? Take a pharmaceutical company,
right? What's a discrete risk? First,
you got three stages to the FDA approval
process. In each stage, you can get
approved, not approved. If you don't get
approved, the game ends. If you get
approved, then you follow to the next
stage. We have discrete risk that are in
a sense on top of each other. A decision
tree works. So, this is what a decision
tree will look like. Don't let it
intimidate you. This is a diabetes drug
that effectively you're trying to value
today at the start of the process. And
essentially takes you through each
sequence. stage one, stage two, stage
three. And in each sequence, what's
happening? You either succeed or fail.
And if you succeed, you're getting
information about what to do in the next
sequence. You can actually take this
decision tree and it's called rolling it
back and effectively start with the end
nodes and work it back one stage at a
time and you can get an expected value.
You will get exactly the same value as
you would get using an option pricing
model.
Now this morning I had somebody in my
MBA class who's going to work for
Novartis pharmaceutical company. He's
very caught up in option pricing because
it looks like something you could use.
And I said why don't you try decision
trees first because it's actually much
more intuitive. Most people can relate
to decision trees. You bring out the
blacks model. It's like bringing a
bazooka launcher out to kill an ant,
right? And it's just too much to do. So
sometimes it's better not to bring the
option pricing out when you can use
traditional probabilities and statistics
and decision trees to capture what you
want to
do. Your
question so here's what we're going to
do
right. We're going to take a bunch of
real option with each one. I'm going to
start by introducing the option with a
payoff diagram. Say this is why there's
an option. Second stop I'm going to talk
about where the exclusivity comes for
that particular option. And third, I'm
going to try an option pricing model.
Sometimes with basis, sometimes kind of
stretching the definition to value the
option. So I'll go back to the start of
the session on Monday when I talked
about how in traditional capital
budgeting, you take the cash flows, you
take the discount rate, and you come up
with the present value, and you come up
with an NPV. And when you do that, you
miss three big options. So first is the
option to delay. Now if you have the
exclusive rights of project it might not
look good but it could look good in the
future. The second is the option to
expand where if this project gives you
information you might be able to do a
second project especially in a big
market of immense value and the third is
the option to
abandon. So what I'd like to talk about
is examples of options to delay that
have real relevance and some of you are
working with companies where I think the
option to delay kicks in and then we'll
talk about the option to expand and the
option to
abandon. The option delay comes to the
fact that you have exclusive rights to a
project. Let's say right now the project
is not viable. The net present value is
negative. The right basically means that
this project could become valuable in
the future. So this is the starting
question for today. So if I were to draw
the payoff diagram of the option to
delay, here's what it would look like.
You can take the project at any time
during the 10 years, you have the rights
to do it. That becomes the equivalent of
the strike price. The underlying asset
becomes a project you will take. So the
present value of those cash flows become
like the S in the model. If the present
value of cash flows exceeds what you
will need to invest, you will take the
project, keep the difference. If that
never happens, the right expires
worthless.
Are you familiar with how patents work
in the US? Somebody Tyler what is it?
How does a patent work?
Something. And who gives you this
right? The US government basically,
right? You have to file with the patent
office. If they approve the right, you
get the rights to the next 70, the next
20 years. And you have exclusive rights
to whatever you've patented. In the US,
you can patent all kinds of stuff.
Sometimes look at things patented really
you can patent that the way you package
a box can be patented you get exclusive
rights during that period you and only
you can develop this patent you see the
structure here for an option let's say
you have a patent okay you have the
right to develop the patent let's say it
cost you I I can be I 100 million500
that becomes the equivalent of the
strike price would you develop the
patent depends on what you think the
cash flows from developing the patent
Sorry. If that present that present
value of the cash flows is V, you will
develop the patent if the present value
of the cash flows exceeds the cost
developing the patent. If that doesn't
happen, there's no guarantee it will
doesn't. What happens? Then end of the
period you throw the patent in the trash
can say I wish I hadn't spent the money
acquiring that patent. You ready for the
payoff diagram? The cost of converting
the patent into a product becomes the
equivalent of the strike price. You will
develop the patent only if the present
value the cash flows from developing it
exceeds that
cost. But if that never happens, you
lose what you paid to get the patent.
Remind me again how companies end up
with
patents. What are the two ways in which
patents can end up? You buy patent. One
is you can buy a patent and let somebody
Sophia, what's the other way? File your
own patent.
But where did that patent come from?
Right. By the time you file the patent,
somebody must have developed it within
basically it'll be the R&D you spend to
develop the patent. So that becomes the
cost of the option. R&D is really money
you're spending to buy options as a
pharmaceutical company, as a technology
company. There's an option here, right?
One of the things I find troublesome
with real options books, they talk in
the abstract. So I want to make this
real. Let's say you want to actually
value a patent. Let's see how we'd come
up with the inputs you would need to
value the patent. Let's start at the
top. You need a value for the underlying
asset. Remind me again what the
underlying asset here is. Do you have a
patent?
Sophia,
the product that comes out of the patent
and then the the S will be the present
value of the cash flows. If you develop
the patent today, will that require
work? Yes, it'll be like a capital
budgeting exercise, right? Project
revenues, project margins, project cash
flows, take the present value. That'll
become the S. What's the variance in
that
value? When you do a present value
calculation, you did a DCF, right? You
got expected cash flows, you got a
discount rate, you got a value. Could
that value change
tomorrow? Yeah. Could change the next
moment? Probably change today while you
were sitting here because everything
shifts. The variance in the value
basically comes from the fact that that
present value you compute will change
over time. And there are two ways you
can estimate that variance. One is you
can do a Monte Carlo simulation.
Remember we talked about this in the
context of valuing companies like oil
companies where you let the oil price
vary. Now Monte Carlo simulation you get
a present value. You get a standard
deviation that present. That's a lot of
work though. If you're lazy like me,
there's a second way you can do this.
Let's say your patent is in
biotechnology. What if I could give you
the standard deviation of stock prices
in biotech companies? It's it's lazy and
sloppy, but think of how much time you
save and use that as the standard
deviation in your present value. So I've
got S, I've got sigma or variance.
What's the exercise price? You got to
develop the patent. The cost of
developing the patent becomes the strike
price you will
use. What's the life of this
option? What's it? What's the option
here? It's the patent, right? What's the
life of the option? It's whatever years
you have left on the patent, 15 years,
17 years, 20
years. And finally, when you look at
dividend yield, here's what I'm asking.
If your patent becomes
viable, you might be tempted to wait and
collect more information and come up
with a better product, which I
understand. But is there a cost to
waiting here once a patent becomes
viable? Jake, what's the cost?
It's not just time value. It's
protection, right? What does a patent
give you? gives you protection against
competition. If you wait, you're giving
up some protection. There's a cost to
delay. It's messy valuing patents. Why?
Because much of the information you need
is internal information. It's not
something you can observe from the
outside. So, I'm going to give you an
example of a patent I valued. And this
is almost 27 years old. And re the
reason I've stuck with it is this was
one of those rare cases where I was able
to get my hands on the numbers that a
company
had. It's a company called Biogen. It's
still around, but at that time it was a
young biotech company. It had two drugs
that had already developed that it had
licensed out to other pharma companies.
We'll come back to those two drugs. But
the big draw in this company was a drug
that was work that had worked its way
through the pipeline and it passed
through all three stages of the approval
process called Avenex, the drug to treat
MS. And what gave me the advantage here
was I was able to get my hands on an
internal cash flow analysis that Biogen
had done on Avenex. If any of you guys
ever get your hands on how farmer
companies estimate cash flows in a drug,
it's both a scary and a morbid
exercise. Here's what they do. They
start with the percentage of pe the
population that has MS. They have a
pretty good sense of the percentage of
people who will go to a doctor and it's
not
100%. And the percent of people who go
to a doctor who get the right diagnosis,
which is not 100% either. And among the
person people who get the right
diagnosis, a percentage of people who
can afford to take the drug. So you can
start with 8 million people having MS
and by the time you're done 2 million
will be a potential market. Then you set
a price for the drug and what drives
that? What you can negotiate with the
insurance company and get away with and
you come up with expected and use cash
flows. And they've done that and the
present value they came up with was
about
3,422 million developing the drug today.
the present value. So traditional
capital budgeting it they estimate it
would cost them 2,875 million to
actually develop the drug. Why so much?
Because Biogen had never marketed drug
on their own. They'd licensed drugs out
so they have to build up an entire sales
force. Incredibly expensive process
2.875 billion. If I stopped right there
and this were a capital budgeting
exercise, the present value of the cash
flows is 3,422 million. The initial
investment is 2875 million. What's that
difference going to
be? What do I get when I take the
present value of the cash flows and
subtract out initial investment in
capital
budgeting? I'm going to get an NPV. In
this case, I'm going to get an NPV of
547 million. Put that to the side.
That's my DCF value for this drug. But
remember, they haven't developed the
drug yet. There's 17 years left on the
patent. There's a lot of uncertainty
about the future and here I'm going to
cheat and use the standard deviation of
publicly traded or the variance of
publicly traded biotech companies
because I can't do a simulation. I'm
going to make that the variance in my
cash flows. So there's a lot of
uncertainty about what will happen to
that S and I put in a cost to delay. Why
a cost? Is this a viable drug? Net
present value is 547 million positive. I
should be taking the drug, right? So why
am I waiting? because I can learn more
about the drug, the side effects, I can
make a better drug. So that part of it
pushing me to wait, but if I do wait,
I'm going to give up one out of those 17
years of protection from competition.
That becomes my cost of
delay. I'm trying to force the company
to develop the drug because if I don't,
they won't develop the drug till the
last day of the 17th year.
So I plugged the numbers into the black
shores model and the value that I got
for Avenex as an option is $97
million. And there are two things. One
is financial and the other
is social. Let's see what the financial
implication of this is. This drug is an
NPV of 547 million but an option value
of 97 million. So if I'm buying the
company that option value should be what
drives what I pay for the company.
That's the financial implication. But if
you have MS this is really bad
news.
Why? The option value is 97 million.
Right? It's not that they will raise the
price. They won't develop the drug. If
you develop the minute you develop the
drug remember the optionality goes away.
Right? If I develop the drug the value
drops to 547 million. If I wait and do
more research and collect more
information, the value is 97 million. So
while you you with MS are waiting for
the drug,
I'm working on the
drug next year. How about two years from
now? In fact, to see how long you'd have
to wait, I actually computed two
numbers. One is the value of the option.
So that's the blue line.
and the value of developing the drug the
purple line the pre traditional present
value there's a crossing point it
happens about five years from
now and why do you develop then because
at that point in time the value of the
option drops below the
NPV so the bad news here is you're going
to wait 5 years to develop the drug you
know what actually did happen though
biogen developed the drug almost
instantaneously saying those noble
people you know why they developed the
What's keeping me from developing the
drug here? I think I have 17 years of
protection. I'm going to I'm willing to
give up one out of those 17 years.
Right. What am I missing when I do that
Sophia? If
it's medicine or patent many countries
there is this thing called force
licensing. That's not in the US though.
That so they don't have to worry about
that, right? So they can't for you can't
you can't be forced to do it. But what
does a patent give me protection
against? It doesn't give me protection
against comparatives developing their
own drugs for MS, right? It gives me
protection against somebody using my
compound as an MS drug. What if I threw
into the mix the fact that MK and Up
John were working on their own MS drugs
and were within five years of developing
that drug?
What is the change in the in my model?
So if I said you only five years waiting
one year, what's my cost of delay going
to be? One over five. If I put one over
five is my cost today. The value of the
option completely
implodes. If you're in a comparative
pharmaceutical business, the optionality
starts to dissipate because exclusivity
is starting to slip away, right? The
exclusivity came from the option from
the pat from the from the patent. But to
the degree that there are other people
working on other drugs for the same
disease, you're going to develop your
drugs much more
quickly. I've never been a fan of
monopolistic pharmaceutical companies.
There's only one pharmaceutical company
in the country. God help you, right?
They're going to wait a long time to
develop drugs cuz who's going to get in
the
way? So when you look at options in the
patent business, that's a factor. So I
value Abin X as a drug. I want to try to
value Biogen as a company. When you look
at Biogen as a or any farmer company,
you can value it in three slices. First
is the drugs that they already have out
there that they've developed already.
That's traditional cash flows of DCF
valuation. The second is drugs like
Avenex that they've been approved to
produce but they haven't pulled the
trigger yet. They haven't decided
whether to develop or not. Those are
options. And there's a third slice which
is every pharmaceutical company has an
ongoing R&D department, right? How would
you value just the R&D department or
pharma
company, you're going to get negative
cash flows from the spending you do?
What do you hope to get as
positives or the patterns they might
come up with or might not come up with
in year 1, year two, year three? Could
an R&D department be value
destroying? Yeah, you spend a lot of
money, they don't come up with any very
many new drugs. It could be value
creating, value neutral. You got to make
a judgment in my company which of those
three scenarios will kick in. Sophia
well in
department to adjust for example for
person or whatever you could you might
if it's a key scientist but remember the
when you look at most pharma companies
there is no star scientists it's a group
of scientists you have a great lab so
much of the value from the R&D
department might come from things that
so if you look at Mona and say who
created mRNA it's probably a team of
people and Mona gets to use that mRNA on
whatever new drugs come out. But if
there's one person who's a big deal
here, then you worry about that key
person discount that we talked about in
the private company valuation
selling the drug. Yeah. 17
years that maybe the company won't last
that long because it might be, but if
you have a if you have a blockbuster
drug, it's not about the company, right?
It's about the drug. So if the drug is
producing cash flows, even if the
company goes under, you could sell the
rest of the drug. That's one of the
easier things to get in a liquidation
value is what people will pay for the
cash flows on the
drug. So here's what I'm going to do to
finish my biogen valuation. So I have
the Avenex, which is their only big
patent I valued as an option. They had
two existing drugs out there that they
had already reduced, but they they'd
already been approved for, but they
licensed out. One was I think licensed
out to Merc and the other to Up
John and they were getting there are two
ways you can license a drug out. One is
for fixed fees every year contractually
set and the other is a percentage of
revenues. I want you to file the two way
because I'm going to ask you a very
specific question about coming up with
the value. Biogen was collecting 50
million in licensing
fees on these two drugs and they were
fixed fees. What do you have to do? You
have to compute the present value of 50
million a year, right? What discount
rate should I use on that 50 million in
cash flows? This could very well be a
question on the final. So, I want you to
think about it. What is the discount
rate I would use to discount the 50
million in cash flows from those two
drugs?
You could, but what's a what kind of
claim is this? Go ahead, William. I was
going to say like
to replicate this borrow.
It's a guarantee claim. It's not an
equity claim. It's a guaranteed claim.
Right? The only thing is the guarantors
might default. In this case, Mercur
John. So the risk you face is the risk
of default in those companies. Sophia
or the cost of debt for the client,
right? Because that's what the cost of
debt is. the cost to so I would I
actually took the 50 million discounted
back at a pre-tax cost of debt for Merk
and up John the 7%. Why pre-tax? Because
the licensing fees were pre-tax and what
I got as a present value was the present
value of those existing products. Now an
I'm going to come back to you. I could
have redesigned this licensing agreement
but instead of getting a fixed fee I got
a percentage of revenues every year. If
that's the way the contract is
structured, what discount rate should I
use on that?
Cost of capital. Whose cost of capital?
Those firms that are
okay. So if it's person, what if it's
percentage of net income? What would I
use that? Yeah,
we got it right. So basically, you tell
me how your cash flows are structured.
What if I had this with the government
instead of up John and Mark? What would
I discount? And this were a guaranteed
contract. What did I use as my discount
rate then? Risk-free rate. Discount
rate. So don't get trapped into cost of
equity. You I know you've learned all
this stuff about cost of equity and
capital. You feel the urge to pull out
betas and risk premiums. Don't do it if
I've given you a guaranteed cash flow
because that's a very different set of
cash flows. So in this case, the present
value of 50 million a year for 12 years
because that's how long the the license
ran at the pre-tax cost of debt of the
guarantors not of Biojet gave me 397
million. And then I got to the R&D
department and I'm going to do some
handwaving. I have no idea what Biogen's
R&D department will do in the future,
but I do have a sense of their history,
right? And over the 10 years Biogen had
been around, they'd been pretty
successful. that it turned out three
pretty big blockbuster drugs and I think
they can continue to do this. So to
value my continuing R&D, here's what I'm
going to start with. I'm first going to
estimate how much money Biogen will
spend on R&D every year for the next 10
years. So let's put a 20% growth rate on
R&D expenses. That's how much they're
going to spend. And now comes the leap
of
faith. They're going to spend 150
million next year 120 million next year
on R&D. question is how much value will
that 120 million
create? Based on Biogen's history and
looking at what biotech companies earn
as return on capital over and above the
cost of capital, they generally earn
excess returns. I assume that a dollar
invested in R&D at Biogen would create
a$125. See, how do you know? I don't.
That's my estimate. I am assuming that
Biogen's R&D department will continue to
create value for the next 10 years. What
happens after year 10? I think it's
going to become it's not like the R&D
will go away, but it'll create it'll
become more of a neutral R&D. It'll
create a dollar in value for a dollar
spent. So for the next 10 years, I'm
going to have excess cash flows over and
above what I need to make. And I take
the present value of those excess cash
flow. So there's my R&D cost multiplied
by 1.25 gives me the cash flow or the
value that I will get in year one. The
difference is the value created and in
the last column I take the present value
of that value created every year for the
next 10 years.
What I get by adding up those numbers is
about 318 million. That is the value of
continuing
R&D at Biogenet. Let's do a few whatifs.
What if a dollar in value what dollar
money spent in R&D creates a dollar in
value? The excess value will go to zero.
The R&D becomes a
non-factor. Could it be that you could
invest for every money dollar you spend
in R&D, you get only 80 cents back in
value? In which case, what is R&D doing?
It's making your company less valuable.
I talked a little bit about remember we
talked about Merc when I talked about
AMS and it's a few sessions ago how over
the last 15 years Merc has spent tens of
billions of dollars in R&D and has very
little to show for it. I'm convinced
that at Merc the R&D added on is
actually reducing the value of the
company.
Put simply, if they shut their R&D
department down, send everybody home,
their stock price would jump 20%. It's a
very perverse way of thinking about R&D.
You're not creating value. That's how
it's going to play
out. So, in the case of buyers, when you
add the three numbers up, the total
value you get is 1.622 billion.
value the the the the two products
they've already licensed value of Abanex
as a as an option and the value the
continuing
R&D and a few of you are valuing young
farmer companies or biotech companies
for this project you're using a
traditional DCF right where in a
traditional DCF of biogen would I be
able to reflect this view about R&D and
Abinex
one is through the growth right I would
say look biogen is going to have high
revenue growth because there's this drug
waiting in the pipeline a ax that's
going to come in what's the second
margins right high margins because you
have the protection for the next 17
years are going to be able to earn
higher margins and when it comes to
reinvestment I'll have a low
reinvestment why because I've already
spent the money on R&D to get the
drugs if you do that don't add the value
of ax as an option on top of your DCF
Why
not be double counting, right? You
count. So if you do a traditional
DCF, be careful about adding the value
of an entire option on top because that
would be double counting something
you've already
counted. So let's pass the patents uh
the patent through the three the three
tests. I said is there an option in a
patent? Absolutely. The underlying asset
is the drug that comes out of the
patent. The contingencies the present
value of the cash flows and the drug
exceeds the cost of developing you'll
develop it. If not you won't. So it
passes the option test. Is there
exclusivity? Technically yes. Right.
Where does the exclusivity come from?
The US government stands behind your
right to develop the drug. But it's
limited exclusivity to the extent that
there's competition and other people can
develop their comparative drugs and
there the exclusivity starts to fade.
And third, I'm using an option pricing
model to value this option. Option
pricing models require replication and
arbitrage. You see, what does it even
mean? Replication requires that I be
able to trade the option, trade the
underlying asset, and borrow and lend
money at the riskless rate. Take out the
third requirement. Can I trade this
option? Can I go to Bloomberg and check
what the price of a next the patent is
not traded?
I can't trade the patent. I can't trade
the drug.
Obviously, this is as far as you get
from being able to meet the requirements
for option pricing. Doesn't mean I can't
use an option pricing model, but it's
tough to monetize
it. So, there is an option, there is
exclusivity, but it gets very shaky on
the pricing part because it's much
tougher to get those
inputs. So, that's the first real option
pattern. You can see it applies, but you
can see why people don't actually try to
price the option. They talk about it and
they can talk about its value, but they
often leave it as is. It's worth a
lot. I'm going to take a second example
of the option to delay. Say you're an
oil company. Your value comes from two
places. One is reserves you've already
developed, which you where you do what?
You get the oil out of the ground, you
sell the oil, you get the cash flows,
you take the present value. Traditional
DCF, right? But every oil company also
has undeveloped reserves. Let's play out
why it's an option. You have undeveloped
reserves. You have the option to develop
those reserves. Let's see what drives
that option. There's a cost to
developing the reserves, right? You got
to put up the rigs and expensive
process. And there's value of oil under
the ground. If the value of the oil
under the ground exceeds the cost to
developing the reserves, it's an in the
money option. You develop it, you keep
the difference.
If that doesn't happen, the reserves
will expire worthless. It's like a call
option. In fact, if I draw the payoff
diagram, here's what it looks like. The
cost of developing the reserve becomes
equivalent to the strike
price. The value of oil under the ground
becomes like a stock price. The value of
the oil in the ground
exceeds that cost of development. You
develop the reserves, keep the
difference. And if that never
happens, you lose whatever you paid to
get these reserves. Remind me again how
you get reserves. Claire, how do you get
reserves as an oil? She's my oil expert.
So
she under reserves in general. How do
oil companies end up with reserves? They
acquire one is they acquire reserves or
acquire other oil companies. The other
is they do exploration and hope they
explore like the equivalent of R&D
hoping find reserves.
you paid for those reserves. If they end
up worthless, you end up losing. So that
becomes the price of the option. And
here I think we have an advantage in
being able to get the inputs. And to see
why, let's go through each of the
inputs. First to value an undeveloped
reserve, I've got to get an estimate of
the value of the oil under the
ground. How do oil companies know? I
mean, they they have all these reserves.
They have how do they know how many
barrels of oil there are under the
ground?
This geologist goes and taps on rocks
and lots of oil here, not so much oil
here. And before we dump on them, let's
face it, they're much better than equity
research analysts in their estimates.
So, let's go with that. So, 100 million
barrels of oil and you, you
know, you multiply it by the oil price,
you take out the cash flow. So, that is
the value you'd get if you develop the
reserves today. That becomes the S in
the
model. What's the K? It's a cost of
developing those
reserves. Do all companies have a pretty
good sense of what it would cost them to
develop
reserves? It's going to be very
different in the Gulf of Mexico as
opposed to Canada. It's going to be very
different in Canada as opposed to Saudi
Arabia. Saudi Arabia, it's, you know,
oil's very close to the ground. You cost
of development might be low. In Canada,
it's 5,000 ft under the ground and
frozen. You got to dig your way down,
unfreeze it, pain in the neck and know
much bigger cost. That becomes the K in
the model. What will it cost to develop
these
reserves? How many years do you have to
do this? Usually, if you get the
reserves in an auction, you don't get
them forever. The US government auctions
off reserves. It's 12 years, 15 years at
the end of which it goes back to the
government. That becomes a life of the
option. What's the uncertainty you feel
about the value? If you're an oil
company, you know the reserve the market
for oil. It's the oil price can of
course the reserve amounts can change.
But geologists don't change their mind
from 100 million to 10 million to a,000.
It's basically the oil price that's a
big
uncertainty. And here we have an
advantage. Do we know what the variance
in oil prices is? Or is there a place to
observe it? There's a market out there.
I've been tracking Brent crude all
month. Why? Just because I feel like it.
It's in that table with the equity risk
premiums. I've been tracking everything
else. You can go look it up every moment
of every day. And that's an advantage. I
can look unlike with a patent where to
do a simulation or play these games
about where to get here. I can observe
the
variance and to complete the process I
do need to introduce a cost of delay. Do
you see why you have undeveloped
reserves that become viable? What do I
want you to do?
develop the reserves and get the oil out
of the ground. And if I don't put a prod
in, you will never develop these
reserves. You let them go until the very
last day of the last year that you have
the rights and try to get all the oil
out of the ground in one day. You can't
do
that. And my cost of delay here is if
you if your reserves become viable and
you choose not to develop it, you give
up the cash flows you could have got by
developing the reserves. So that becomes
like a dividend yield, cost of delay.
And there's one final aspect of natural
resource
reserves that you have to incorporate.
Let's say oil prices go to 120 barrel
dollars a barrel tomorrow and Exon
Mobile decides it's going to develop all
its undeveloped reserves
tomorrow. So guy some guy in Exxon
Mobile headquarters picks up the phone.
They're still oldfashioned there. They
call everybody in the world at one go
say develop the reserves right away.
Does the oil start to come out of the
ground the next day? Takes a while,
right? Might take two years. You're
saying so what what are the what could
happen during those two years? The first
120 can become
60 as the first and the second there is
a time value of money there right you
now that's going to reduce the value of
my option I've got to bring it in.
Sophia is that to account for the way
that that sometimes you may need to For
example, if you have a lot of reserves,
but
your like ability to
refine the res there's a limit to how
much oil you can get out of the ground.
So if you develop reserves, it's not
like all the oil comes out of the
ground. It might have to come out over
15 years because the rest of your
capacity is the way to bring it in. When
you do the present value, you build in
the expected cash flows each year with
these constraints built in. But often
you can lock in the forward price of oil
if you choose to as an oil company,
right? Because there is a forward market
out there. You're not at the mercy of
the oil price changing year to year. So
you want to lock it in, you can do it.
There's a downside to doing that because
the oil then goes up. You lose that
upside. But if you wanted to lock in the
cash flows, you can. But you can bring
in the constraints through those
expected cash flows every
year. So let's talk about the inputs
that you would need. And I'm going to
use a company to illustrate this process
from way back in time 1984. An oil
company called Gulf Oil was targeted an
acquisition partly because it had huge
undeveloped reserves. 3,38 million
barrels of oil under the ground and the
estimate then was to develop these
reserves would cost about $10 a barrel.
So collectively 30.38 billion to develop
the reserves.
At that time, the oil price was
$22.38 per barrel. And the variable cost
of extracting the oil out was about $7 a
barrel. So each barrel of oil, you're
making
$15.38. So you have 3,38 million barrels
of oil.
$15.38 per
barrel. They had 12 years left on their
reserves. That's a period over which
they could exercise this right. The the
T-bond rate then was 9%. very different
point in time in US market history. And
one final point, there was a development
lag of about two years in developing the
reserves. And if they did develop the
reserves, their cash flows would be
about 5% of the value of the reserves.
That's what they would give up if they
decided not to develop the reserves. I'm
going to try to value these undeveloped
reserves as options. What's the first
step? I take the 3,38 million barrels of
oil, assume I can extract the oil and
sell it at today's price. Net of the
variable cost it's 1538 per barrel. Of
course I lose those two years that I
can't develop that development lag. I
bring that in I get $42.38 billion as
the value of the oil under the
ground. My development cost is 30.38
billion. I take the difference 12
billion. That's my discounted cash flow
valuation for these reserves. But let's
finish the process. These are reserves
that are undeveloped. They haven't
developed them yet. There's optionality.
I bring in the life 12 years, the
variance in oil price which I can
observe to be
0.03. I put in the cost of delay 5% each
year. And I value the option. And what I
get as a value for the option is $13.3
billion. Let me pause right there. My
DCF value for these reserves is 12
billion. Where's the extra 1.3 billion
value magically coming from?
Where's that premium coming
from? But what did have to happen for
that premium to
disappear? And if I took the oil out of
the ground, it's 12 billion. I'm paying
an extra 1.3 billion because oil prices
are
volatile. If oil prices became
guaranteed fixed, that premium would
disappear. The value of the option comes
from the fact that oil price at
$22.38 now, but they could go to 40 or
50 or 60. This is the premium created by
the optionality by the fact that I can
choose when to exercise the
option. That's what makes real options
so attractive to people is you add a
premium onto your DCF value effectively
when you do that. So that's the value of
my undeveloped reserves, 13.3 billion.
And if I wanted to complete my Gulf oil
valuation, here's all I need to do. Take
the o the oil that they're already
developing and treat it as a traditional
discounted cash flow valuation. They're
getting about $915 million in cash flows
every year. They expect to get these
cash flows for the next 10 years. I
apply a cost of capital. So traditional
DCF valuation, I get a valuation of
about 5.07 billion for the developed
reserves. The 13 billion 13.3 billion
for the undeveloped reserves gets added
on. The sum of those two values
becomes the equivalent of what you'd
have got in a DCF by discounting cash
flows back at the cost of cap for the
entire company. If I'd been valuing this
oil company in a traditional DCF, the
way I would have give brought in the the
fact that they have a lot of undeveloped
reserves is given them a higher growth
rate, less
reinvestment. And again, make your
choice. You either can work through the
DCF and miss the optionality, which is
okay, but the one thing you can't do is
do a DCF and add the 13.3 billion to
your DCF because then you'll be double
counting those same undeveloped
reserves. So with commodity companies,
you can value the company in pieces as
developed and undeveloped reserves, and
that's something that will factor into
how a an oil company's stock price
reacts to what's happening in the
market.
option to delay. Let's talk about the
option to expand. The option to expand
is truly one of the most scary things
we've invented in finance because it
gives you an excuse to do really stupid
things and get away with it. And here's
why it's dangerous. The option expand is
built around two projects that are bound
together at the head. You got to take
the first project to do the second
project. And the first project is a
negative net present value project.
Already you're getting a little wary,
right, Nick? But here's what the the
negative net present value project gives
you the rights to an even more negative
net present value project in the future
if you choose to take it. This sounds
like you're going it's going from bad to
worse, right? But here's what makes that
second project palatable. It's a really
big negative net present value project
today, but it could change in the
future. Are companies investing a lot in
AI right now?
Do you think if you did a capital
budgeting analysis of what Meta is
investing in AI or Microsoft's investing
AI that the net present value would be
positive? I don't think so. So why are
they doing it? Because if AI turns out
to be as big a market as we think it is.
They're hoping that this initial
investment will give them the option to
expand into that
market. and they're therefore
overlooking the net present value being
negative on the first investment because
they get a re they get an option to
expand that's worth a lot. I know it
sounds abstract but if I did a payoff
diagram here's what it would look like.
The additional investment you'll have to
make to expand into that big market if
it does show up will become the
equivalent of the strike price. Would
you expand? You would expand only if the
present value of the cash flows from
expansion exceed the cost of expansion.
And is it possible that that never
happens that the And if that h never
happens then what have you lost?
The first investment I said is a
negative net present value. Just write
it off. That 10 billion you spend write
it off. And the bigger the market is the
more the attraction of the option to
expand. I'm going to argue that this was
the basis for many US companies
investing in China 20 years ago. It's a
big market. we're going to make money
investing in India right now, investing
in AI, investing in dot in the '90s, big
market option to expand. You're willing
to overlook the fact that you're
overspending now because you think the
option to expand you get is going to be
so valuable. So, I'm going to give you a
very simplistic example of the option to
expand which might color how you think
about the DCF value for your company.
So, think about what you've done right
now, right? take at the expected cash
flows based on the business or
businesses you think your company's
going to be in discount in the back at a
risk adjusted discount rate to come up
with the value. Say I did this for a
company that produces security
software and I come up with $115 million
is the value of the company and then I
throw in a wild card. I said this
company is selling its software to
clients and it's collecting data from
these clients about threats to their
system. It's I have the proprietary data
on these threads. Somewhere in the next
five years, I can take that data and
create a second
business. Let's call it the database
business. Seems like a reach, right? And
I give you some numbers. I say if I did
that today, the cash flows I will get
from doing it are going to be $40
million a year for the next 10 years.
But it's going to cost me a half a
billion dollars to do it. Even without
doing time value of money, you can see
this doesn't look good, right? You spend
a half a million and you get 40 million
every year for 10 years. Even without
discounting, you're already underwater,
right? And this is a risky business. You
think, who cares? And many of you have
companies where there are other things
they could do. You look at say no, it's
not going to work. I'm going to give you
a hook that you might use to argue for a
premium on your DCF. In this case, I'm
going to treat that second the the
second business as an option. What are
the characteristics of the option? If I
took the present value of 40 million a
year at the 12% cost of capital, I get
226 million. That's well below the half
a billion that I have to invest. It's a
negative net present value of minus 274
million. But here's the saving grace.
That second business is incredibly
risky. And normally that would be a bad
thing, right? But here's the good thing.
I haven't made the investment yet. If I
throw in that high risk 50% standard
deviation, the value that I get for that
second business, that option to expand
as an option is 56 million. A project
with a negative net present value of
minus 226 million, a really risky
business, has huge option value because
you're
uncertain. Again, if you think about the
implications, you could see why
companies enter into risky big
businesses and are okay with losing
money because they say it's really
incredible option out there. So, when
you look at the option to expand, that
becomes the driving factor. But here are
some questions to ask whenever you hear
this argument being made. It'll be made
as a strategic expansion, a real option
argument. First question you got to ask
is do I have to take the first
investment to get to the second one?
Because if I can unbundle the two, why
are you forcing me to take that first
project which is bad? Second, assuming I
have to take the first investment to get
to the second one, how much exclusivity
is there on the second investment? That
software company, what's the question
you need to ask them? You're collecting
data, but what is unique about the data?
What is exclusive about the data?
And I have piece on big data where I
argue that most big data is worthless.
Why? Because everybody has it. What kind
of data? Your location data. If you get
a chance, check your smartphone. Check
how many apps know your location. I
checked I think a couple of weeks ago,
27 apps know where I am at every point
in the day. I really don't care. But if
they tried to tell me I have data on
you, my response is, "So do 26 other
apps. My apps all know where I am more
than my spouse
does. But it doesn't make any
difference. There's nothing
exclusive. Data to have value has to be
exclusive. And that's the question
that's going to drive whether you attach
a high value or low value to this
option. So if you were to pass the
option to expand through the test, let's
go through them. Is there an option
here? Yes. The underlying asset is that
expansion you hope to make in the
future. The contingency is the value of
the cash flows exceeds the cost of
expanding you will take the project if
not you
won't is there exclusivity varies right
so when a company says we can do other
stuff the question I'm going to ask is
where is the exclusivity it's become a
big argument when you value platform
companies you know what I mean by
platform companies Facebook Twitter is
there a value to having a lot of people
on your platform yes could you do other
stuff maybe, but I think Facebook is in
a better position to do it than Twitter
is because people on its app are
stickier. You have more
people. So the questions you would ask
in attaching that option will vary
depending on whether you have
exclusivity and how strong it is. And
thirdly, when I use an option pricing
model, as I just did in the last page,
to value that option, I'm really
stretching the limits of option pricing.
The option is not traded. the underlying
asset is not traded. I'm just making up
stuff as I go along on variance. And so
you're really pushing the limits, but
that doesn't mean that you won't use the
logic. What I want you to take out of
real options is not the black shows
application, but the mindset that comes
with it. Seven years ago, remember
Facebook had the Cambridge Analytica
scandal. It stock price
dropped. Now, I'd never owned Facebook
till then. Actually, let me take it
back. 2012, right after the IPO, I owned
them for a brief period. In 2017, when
the stock price dropped, I valued
Facebook and I got a value roughly equal
to the stock
price and I bought the
company. People said, why are you buying
the company? It's fairly valued. And I
said, I'm valuing it as an online
advertising company, but I'm not
factoring in the reality. They have
billions of people on their platform
that they could do other
stuff right now. It might not be viable
but there is optionality there. Many of
your companies might be close to fairly
valued as you make that decision as to
whether to buy the company. One of the
question to ask is is there some
optionality? I mean I know people are
valuing
Pelaton. Is there any optionality there?
Maybe we stretch the definition of
exclusivity, right? you have a special
subset of people on your
platform. But to the degree that there's
exclusivity, you can argue that many of
these platform companies, you're paying
more than just the DCF value because
you're getting that additional premium.
So I'm going to pause there. But now
when I get when we start back up on
Monday, we're going to talk about the
option to abandon and then talk about
how distressed equity in companies take
on the features of not.
Yes sir. So in the beginning of class
you mentioned there are six variables
that dictate an options value. There's
the value the underlying asset value the
variance in the value. So that's the the
Vega right sigma. Oh the sigma. Okay.
There's the interest rates. And then
what were the other three? Do you do you
listen strike price in the life of the
option? Huh? And then the dividend.
Sure. Okay.
So the dividend yield the Y and the
model.
Which model are you looking? I just I
put this up. So this is sigma because
it's that's sigma that's not
that's sigma that's the s in the
model price is
the interest rates are the
in life is the in the model dividends
are the y and the okay
what is the option is a way to value you
know very young companies like startups
because I mean there's some optionality
right I mean but the question is is
there are you just valuing don't mistake
opportunities for options so young
companies we have big market you can say
that cash flows can potentially go out
that's why I'm paying a large amount the
optionality comes in only if you believe
that if the company succeeds in one
business it can do other businesses as
well right now you don't know what those
businesses It just with this you know
like that many more companies now you
know which IPO before they turn
profitable that and like even when you
talk to VCs and preIPO a lot of the
attention is addressable
marketly option right addressable market
can also show up in potential revenue
growth so you you have a big addressable
market and I do the valuation of your
company I can potentially give you 50%
revenue growth cuz you're going after a
$2 trillion market. So I'm going to
reward you in with a higher revenue
growth because you have a bigger total
addressable market. Optionality actually
comes from beyond. If you reach this
addressable market and you're very
successful, are there other markets you
could go after? So in the case of
Facebook, the addressable market is the
online advertising market which is about
a trillion dollars which is a pretty big
market. But the bigger question of
Facebook is let's say you become a large
part of that online advertising market.
Will that right now? Exactly. Which is
the question is now that you have a
large seg portion of that addressable
market, are there other things you can
do that you would not have been able to
do if you weren't successfully out of
that market. That's the optionality.
It's something you can't see right now,
but you think that success in the market
they're in will allow them. Let's say
Door Dash, right? Let's suppose you
believe it's going to become a
successful online food delivery
business. So you take attention to
market, you come up with the and then
you say if they succeed in that market
and become 45%. Could they own the
restaurants themselves? Right? Could
they go out and become something they
can't do now because they now control
the market? Right? So that's the
optionality. You can't quite name it,
but you think that they're going to get
an advantage in other spaces, which you
can't put into your valuation right now
because it's not viable, but it could
become viable if they succeed on that
first investment that you see them
succeeding in. And so basically then
before we would you know use probability
basically estimate that. So basically
the problem here is right now it's not
viable right so even if you put a
probability it's not going to add to the
value of your company it's contingent on
something happening and then it becomes
viable right so right now if you did an
expected value you won't give much
expected value to those new businesses
because they're not viable. What's
different about options is if you
succeed in the initial business, the
viability of those other businesses
could shift and that you can't capture
in a DCF, right? That's optionality.
That's pure premium coming from the
uncertainty of the businesses you're in.
That's what the real options component
brings in. And that's why you can't
bring it in through traditional cash
flows and discount rate. It's not
because you're not being forwardlooking,
but today when you do the cash flows and
discount rates and those new businesses,
they're not viable. They're not good
businesses. But he's saying there is
optionality there. They could become
good businesses. So right now I don't
think Facebook can make money doing
entertainment with their three billion.
But could that change? Maybe they will
acquire Tik Tok and make it part of
Facebook and then it becomes this viable
second business and that second business
could have value but it doesn't have
value right now. Okay.
How you doing? Uh we spoke to you after
that quiz. about the group situation and
do you want to do as a group of two?
Yeah, we were thinking about like if
that's an option at this point. You have
a limit of eight pages then two
companies pages. Okay. All right. Also
for my DCF you emailed me feedback. I
micro rank. Um I messed so yeah that's I
I did not realize I had to do that page.
So on the front page I did all of that.
I think that was just transferred into
that story so I can see what's going on.
I didn't. So, at first I understand what
the email said because you was it was
like that's why I sent you the picture.
Yeah. Then it then it made sense like I
looked at it and I said no I see the
numbers but I don't see how the story
connects the numbers. So that's what I I
just didn't know. I didn't get that that
much. I appreciate your feedback.
Transfer what you have in that front
page into the story page because that's
what you're going to be turning in with
your final project is just the story
page because I don't want an extensive
write up. So essentially you're going to
give a very short lead into your DCF.
Take a picture of your story page,
attach it in there. Sure. No. Okay. No
worries. I also didn't get feedback. I
don't know if you're still working on it
or there's nothing I'm working on. So,
send me another email.
Okay. Sure. All right. Thank you so much
for questioning. Thank you. Appreciate
it. Take care. Hey, I had a question on
um if you value a real option which has
like semi-exclusivity like a solid brand
value. It'll be so you the option then
you take a portion of that value, right?
So think of it as 01. You have no
exclusivity. You have complete
exclusivity. The option value that you
get from an option pricing model is
complete exclusivity.
Zero is no exclusivity. So you're saying
where in that spectrum between zero and
one is my exclusivity, right? And how do
you kind of calculate that coefficient?
Well, I think it know it depends on what
the exclusivity is in the first place,
right? Okay. Where does it come from?
Okay. which as I said if you have
licensing or a right that emerges and
you're closer to complete exclusivity is
it's I was the first mover you're very
weak exclusivity so you got to tell me
what you think the advantage you're
getting from being in that game first
okay so if you could kind of argue that
there's like a lot of businesses that
could have a first mover like impact
it's very weak there you know it's a
very the the added option value there I
wouldn't even bother right so if their
point is we were there first So what
right others will observe what you do
they they'll just copy you right so
unless you can say we were there first
and we no let me give you an example
you're an electric car company what does
the advantage of being there first give
you set the charger technology you are
the ones who can so you could argue that
every subsequent player has to play by
your rules okay because you already set
this right because otherwise you know
they're already charging station set up
so everybody else now has to kind of
bend which is one of the problems if
you're an electric car company in the US
because Tesla said the reason BYD has
been able to come up with its own
5minute techn you know charging
technologies wasn't as clearly
established there they were able to kind
of break away from the the Tesla model
so lots of ways in which because that's
every company that's what they try to do
they try to create stickiness in the
model exclusivity and the question
they're asking is what are you doing and
how big of a barrier to entry can you
create with what you're doing okay And I
guess if you were trying to create or
find the coefficient for like the I
guess the significance of exclusivity.
It's low or high. So you're not even
putting a number. If it's high then
count the option value. If it's low
don't count it at all and then leave at
that. Okay. Makes thank you. Hey
Professor I just had three questions. So
one of them was um reconciling. So how
is um with the dividend yield being the
cost of delayed cash flows as a
percentage of value. That makes sense.
Mhm. But relating that to 1 over M.
Well, if you have 17 years of
protection, you wait a year, what do you
lose? Is that like a time? Is that like
116th of So basically, it's a very So if
you have nothing else to go on, you just
say I've lost one out of the 17 years.
My cash flows are uniform across time.
That's 117th of my excess cash flows
gone because I didn't exploit it
earlier. Okay? you'd rather use cash
flows if you have it, but if you don't
have it, you're kind of stuck with this
one overnight. It's kind of your best
estimate of how much you give up. Okay,
that makes sense. Yeah. And then the
second question was um you know when
with most um with most options or like
patents or like you mentioned US
government options off like pieces of
the reserves. Um do you is there a
circularity problem there with including
the cost of the option into the cost of
developing the reserve? Um I mean
circularity in what sense though? So the
cost of develop the cost of getting the
option is nothing to do with cost of
developing. They're two separate issues
right when you go by bid the US
government you're not getting you know
all you're getting is 15 years of rights
to develop. There's nothing you're doing
to develop the reserves. You're getting
15 years the right to develop those
reserves. So when you walk out of that
room having won the auction all that's
changed is you now have the right to
develop these reserves in the Alask
whatever right you still face choice of
whether to develop the reserves or not
if you do nothing for the next 15 years
you don't spend any additional money the
end of the 15 years you throw your
option away and you say I wish I hadn't
paid that 250 million up front if you
choose to develop the reserves now your
job begins you got to send the rigs out
you got to put them up. That's that K in
the model. It's not inclusive. The
original cost has already been spent,
right? It's sunk. This is the additional
cost you got to spend to actually
develop the reserve and make it an oil
producing, right? Okay, that makes
sense. And then the last question was on
quiz three. So, you know, the first
question for for quiz three goes um uh
on a consistent EVT basis, which company
is cheaper? So when I did when I was
doing the question um what I ended up
doing was uh because I wasn't sure what
cheaper meant I took um I took but it
said EV to AIDA right yeah the lower EV
to AIDA would be cheaper so the question
and uh if you if you account for
minority interest and minority holdings
you have it's a consistency issue right
what is the it's consolidated it's EV so
consistency basically leaves you with
one path right you got to add the
minority interest subtract the minority
holding because otherwise it's not
consistent. Right. Exactly. Yeah. That
but I went a step further of that and I
compared it to what it was currently
trading at. So with if you if you hadn't
accounted for minority interest that's
what the
EVA is what it's currently trading at.
So do you scale it to something
different? Uh I took a ver so I took a
after I took a version of EV before you
factor in minority interest and holdings
and after you factor in minority
interest and holdings. Okay. And then
but still you'd have to make it into a
multiple of some sort to compare the two
companies, right? Because you have no
dollar values in either company.
Right. Right. Right. Exactly. Uh I guess
in that case uh what I took cheaper to
mean would be would have been what the
company was trading at relative to what
its correct value would be. But you
comparing to the other multiple then
right ultimately there has to be a
comparison. Cheaper means you've got to
compare the two companies. Right. So
cheaper. What did you compare it to to
say it was cheaper? I actually have
So this is what I ended up doing. So
with the giant question marks um I had a
version where I took EBT beta on like a
pure basis after you factored out
minority interest and holdings and then
I took a version of it for what it was
trading at. So that was before that's
where I'm confused. What do you mean
trading at? Right. Right. So I it's
trading at 800 plus. So basically this
this is what it's trading at. Do you
have a different version of what it's
trading at? Cuz this is a traded value.
Right. So you're saying you didn't count
any of the cross holdings? Oh, so 1250
would have been a value after you've
after you've subtracted minority
holdings and included minority interest.
But why am I doing that? Because I want
to be make sure that I'm comparing two
companies and I'm comparing apples to
apples, right? That's the only reason
I'm doing it. It's not a standalone
number. It's a I mean all of pricing is
comparing to something else, right? And
what you're trying to do is make sure
you're being consistent in that
comparison, right? Ah, so that Okay. So
that correction is about exactly to make
sure that the two So let's say one of
these companies had no cross holdings at
all in the other day. Right. Right. If I
did not do this, I would find one of the
companies to be cheap for all the wrong
reasons. Not because it's cheap, but
because I didn't factor in. No. Exactly.
So yeah, so when you do So what what's a
50? So basically you went back to just
this number and this number 1,200 and
1700. Yeah. And then I But what's the
denominator? Oh, it's still it's still
eBar consistency problem. Right. Right.
The 250 is EBITD. It's consolidated.
EBITD includes 100% of the EBITDA. That
makes sense. Of the subsidiary and your
numerator includes only the 60%
in market cap. Right. So the problem is
this multiple internally would be
inconsistent, which means that I'm not
sure what I'd be comparing and I compare
across the two numbers. Right? That
makes sense. So, I'm glad you showed the
first one, otherwise you'd have lost
points if you showed. That is your final
answer. So, yeah. All right. Thank
you for the book. You're welcome.